good morning Hank it's Wednesday we were
gonna have a video from the dftba.com
warehouse today but I thought I'd make
one instead so it appears that more
Americans voted for Hillary Clinton than
Donald Trump in the u.s. presidential
race but the presidential race is
decided by electoral college votes and
Donald Trump won most of them so he is
the president-elect most although
certainly not all of the people watching
this video wanted Hillary Clinton to
become president I know I did and for
many of us the results of the election
are devastating I think part of what
makes it so hard for some people is that
Donald Trump has often attacked not what
his opponents believe but who they are
their race their gender their religion
and more and it is painful and scary to
be called dangerous or less than by a
man who becomes president-elect of the
United States and I don't want to
minimize that fear or trauma because I
believe that it is real and important I
also want to say that I'm sorry I'm
sorry that we have let our political
discourse becomes so hateful and I'm
sorry that we've let our echo chambers
become so sealed off that it is as
unfathomable to me why someone would
support Donald Trump for president as it
is too many Trump supporters why I would
support Hillary Clinton I spoke with
hundreds of undecided voters in the days
before the election and what struck me
most was how different our information
was in many cases we had the same
concerns the environment or health care
or tax policy but we were working with
completely different data sets our
community by the way is also an echo
chamber just 4% of the nerdfighters who
filled out the census this year said
they would vote for Donald Trump but I
don't know how to make our community
more inclusive without opening it up to
cruelty and hatred we have to get better
at listening to each other and
challenging each other constructively
and generously but I worry that the very
architecture of the social Internet
might make that impossible honestly I
feel lost and I'm looking to you for
guidance and clarity as I have for
almost a decade now but the world
doesn't end today as Saladin Ahmed wrote
last night it's our job to fight those
in power and stick up for the powerless
that stays the same no matter who's
president as lin-manuel Miranda wrote I
love this country and there's more work
to do than ever and as Camilla Harris
said this is a time to fight for who we
are I think this will be a tough time in
US history I hope it won't be but I
think it will be but I also think our
nation is and always must be bigger than
any of its leaders and that our leaders
are and always must be answerable to the
so it's always our job to stand together
and make sure the government does its
job that it affords equal protection
under the law to all citizens that the
rights of all are protected and that our
government's policies are fiscally sound
and carefully considered change doesn't
only happen on election night and it
doesn't only happen in the Oval Office
and it is up to us to find the places
where our skills and talents meet the
needs of our community and the world and
to do the hard work to make life better
for all and on that front I am hopeful
so 10 days ago my nephew Orrin was born
and bringing that baby into the world
was an act of hope on the part of his
parents I am glad for their hope and I
am heartened by it
and I do not believe it was misguided
that child was born into an America that
is better than the one his grandparents
were born into and it was made better by
people whose hope from restaurant
counters in Alabama to the beaches of
Normandy helped them to stand together
and hold the line in circumstances
vastly darker than anything I pray most
of us will ever see I don't think hope
is idealistic or silly I think it's the
founding emotion of our species and it's
not naive to hope that we can bend the
arc of American history toward justice
because we've seen our ancestors do that
in the face of unimaginable difficulty
as the great American poet of the human
heart wrote hope is the thing with
feathers that perches in the soul and
sings the tune without the words and
never stops at all take care of yourself
and take care of each other